what happened to Josh Holloway after the
whirlwind success of lost came to an end
what is an actor who once struggled to
book guest roles do after the gleam of
his big break wears off we've got the
whole story for you right here Holloway
was born in 1969 in San Jose California
the second of four brothers when he was
two he moved with his family into a
trailer in George's Blue Ridge Mountains
his acting career got a huge break in
1993 in the form of the Aerosmith music
video for cryin when he played a thief
who tries to snatch Alicia Silverstone's
purse he eventually started grabbing TV
guest roles on shows like Angel and CSI
his most significant pre-loss project
was perhaps the 2002 sci-fi original
movie Sabretooth in which he fights to
survive the rampage of a prehistoric
cats but he was struggling so much that
he almost quit acting to become a
realtor in 2004 later that year though
his career really took off into the
stratosphere in TV streaming age it's
hard to convey just how big a deal lost
was in its heyday averaging over 15
million viewers a week during its first
season it inspired the sort of obsessive
fan culture that makes even Game of
Thrones viewers blush in the modern
media era where nerd culture reigns
supreme
it might be difficult to appreciate how
uniquely dedicated lost fan base was as
loveable rogue James Sawyer Ford
Holloway instantly shot into stardom in
a way he probably never imagined
possible Sharon how to make a girl feel
special
[Music]
incredible Sawyer
one might think becoming a household
name overnight would do wonders for a
Holloway's acting career but that
actually wasn't the case at least not at
first
during lost 2004 to 2010 run the only
outside projects he worked on were just
a few low-budget films it isn't hard to
see why this was the case as he and his
family spent most of the year in Hawaii
while he was shooting the ABC series
Holloway also had to turn down some
major roles because of his grueling
shooting schedule perhaps most notably
the part of gambit in the x-men films
even after lost ended it seemed as if
bad luck would curse Holloway into
becoming a has-been pretty quickly at
one point he was considered for the part
of crossbones in Captain America the
Winter Soldier and he even turned down
the CBS series Person of Interest
because he didn't want to move his
family across the country he would
eventually work his way into more acting
opportunities but it's hard to look past
what could have been if a couple of
those chances had broken in his favor I
was thinking about loss today and how
much I miss it and I'm sure you're sick
of hearing about that stuff but I'm not
my wife tells me that often he does
after struggling to get a serious film
career off the ground in the immediate
years after lost Holloway returned to
the small screen in 2014 as the main
character in the CBS series intelligence
the show was a cyber themed action
adventure thriller that unfortunately
for Holloway only aired 13 episodes
before getting the ax he starred as
Gabriel a tech enhanced man designed to
tackle major threats while working for
US Cyber Command with intelligence CBS
wasn't trying to reinvent the wheel and
there's something to be said for easy to
digest thrillers where the good guys are
capital G good and the bad guys are
shady beyond belief that last it never
lived up to the network's expectations
nor was it ever given a full chance to
find a real audience Holloway eventually
found another winning project in 2016 in
the form of colony a sci-fi drama that
ran on USA Network for three seasons
though it never managed to capture a
significantly large audience it was a
cult hit that was generally well
regarded by critics it even managed to
garner three straight Saturn Award
nominations for best science fiction
television series Colony was set in a
dystopian version of Los Angeles where
residents live under military occupation
by the transitional authority an
organization serving an extra
terrestrial group referred to as the
hosts Holloway starters a former US Army
Ranger an FBI special agent who was
trying to save his missing son nice job
coming off the heels of colony Holloway
landed a role on the upcoming third
season of paramount networks Yellowstone
the show stars Kevin Costner's
billionaire John Dutton the patriarch of
a family that controls the largest
contiguous ranch in the United States
the Dutton's are under constant attack
by those around them and Show co-creator
Taylor Sheridan wants to show to be a
look at a violent world separated from
typical media scrutiny Sheridan has said
the show is both timely and timeless as
much as it explores themes painfully
relevant to the world today it explores
the very essence of family and how the
actions of one member can alter the
course of generations Holloway has
signed on for a season-long arc as a
charming hedge fund manager with
ambitious plans in Montana with a string
of regular TV roles over the last
several years it's safe to say that the
future is now looking bright for Josh
Holloway check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]